comme toute compétition féroce,
va produire de grandes disparités de satisfaction narcissique
et donc aussi beaucoup de solitude, beaucoup de frustration.
Alors il faudra s'attendre à ce que la modernité elle-même,
à l'origine du capital séduction, soit remise en cause.
Je pense notamment à des réactions communautaristes,
de type néofasciste ou religieux.
Mais bon, un tel avenir n'est pas une fatalité.
Une autre voie peut être possible pour penser l'amour.
Mais comment ?
Comment renoncer à la demande hystérique d'être valorisé ?
Et bien, en prenant conscience de ma nullité.
(Rires)
Et oui,
je suis nul.
Mais rassurez vous :
vous aussi.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Nous sommes tous nuls.
C'est assez facile à démontrer cette nullité,
puisque, pour être valorisé,
je demande à l'autre qu'il me désire,
donc c'est que je n'ai pas de valeur en moi-même,
je n'ai pas de valeur en soi.
Nous avons tous, nous feignons tous d'avoir une idole ;
nous feignons tous d'être une idole pour quelqu'un mais, en fait,
nous sommes tous des imposteurs, un peu comme celui qui passe
un seigneur indifférent dans la rue,
alors qu'il a tout prévu, tout calculé,
pour que tous les regards se portent sur lui.
Alors je pense que prendre conscience de cette imposture générale,
qui nous concerne tous,
cela pacifierait nos rapports amoureux.
C'est parce que je veux être adoré, jusqu'au bout de mes ongles,
justifié dans tous mes choix,
qu'il y a une hystérie de la séduction.
Et du coup, je veux paraître parfait,
pour que l'autre m'aime.
Je veux qu'il soit parfait, pour qu'il me rassure sur ma valeur,
et cela donne des couples, obsédés par la performance,
et qui vont se quitter, justement, à la moindre contre-performance.
Alors, à l'opposé de cette attitude,
j'invoque la tendresse, l'amour en tant que tendresse.
Qu'est-ce que la tendresse ?
C'est être tendre, c'est accepter les faiblesses de l'être aimé.
Oh, il ne s'agit pas de se transformer en un triste couple d'aide-soignants.
(Rires)
Pas terrible, ça.
Il y a au contraire beaucoup de charme,
beaucoup de joie dans la tendresse.
Je pense notamment à un type d'humour qui est hélas très peu pratiqué,
et qui est une sorte de poésie de la maladresse assumée,
je pense à l'auto-dérision.
Pour un couple qui n'est plus maintenu,
soutenu par les contraintes de la tradition,
je pense que l'auto-dérision est un des meilleurs moyens de durer.